bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
Franz 24 Mi nombre es Juice Muñoz en
días en los que la batalla de bahamut se
ha convertido en uno de los episodios
fundamentales de la guerra en Ucrania ha
tomado especial relevancia el grupo
Wagner un ejército paramilitar ruso que
se ha atribuido el éxito de cercar a
esta ciudad ucraniana y que lleva meses
siendo la punta de lanza de Rusia en el
conflicto así hablaba su líder
hace tan solo unos días
las unidades del grupo Wagner han
rodeado efectivamente
las tenazas se están cerrando antes
luchábamos contra el ejército ucraniano
profesional pero hoy nos enfrentamos
cada vez más a ancianos y niños
una persona cercana a Vladimir Putin es
la cara visible de un grupo
caracterizado por actuar en la sombra en
numerosas zonas de conflicto por todo el
mundo sus orígenes están en el año 2014
cuando una serie de antiguos
combatientes del cuerpo eslavo
decidieron intervenir en crimea y el
donbas en favor de las fuerzas prorrusas
separatistas y contra el gobierno
ucraniano miembros que en muchos casos
están ligados al ultranacionalismo Ruso
y a la extrema derecha de este país de
hecho su nombre fue escogido en honor a
Richard Wagner el músico favorito de
adolf Hitler
su primer campo de pruebas fue la guerra
civil Siria a partir del año 2015
entraron de lleno en este conflicto para
brindar apoyo al ejército Ruso y
defender los intereses de bashar a
lassat su protección al dictador sirio
cuando estaba cerca de caer y sus
exitosos combates contra estado islámico
aumentaron su fama y sus servicios
fueron codiciados en otras partes del
mundo el grupo Wagner se involucró en
diversos conflictos de países africanos
a cambio de recursos minerales y
petrolíferos algo especialmente
importante para financiarse ya que el
grupo no existe sobre el papel Aunque
Wagner defiende los intereses del
kremlin en cada conflicto donde se ha
implicado
Moscú no lo reconoce de hecho la ley
rusa castiga a Los mercenarios pero
Rusia ha visto a través de Wagner que
puede ganar influencia internacional sin
desplegar a militares oficiales de su
ejército sin contar bajas y sin tener
que responder ante las atrocidades que
pueda cometer el grupo sobre el terreno
método más que rentable
no es el estado las empresas de
seguridad privadas no reflejan los
intereses del Estado ruso
es un negocio privado con intereses
privados ligados a la extracción de
recursos energéticos incluidos diversos
recursos como el oro o las piedras
preciosas
el mayor teatro de operaciones del grupo
es África como se puede observar ha
entrado en combate en conflictos en
Libia Mali burkina faso Sudán república
centroafricana Y mozambique ya ha
participado en otro tipo de operaciones
en casi una veintena de naciones más a
cambio de reclutar tropas o gestionar
directamente explotaciones mineras
además de sus operaciones en África en
América Latina fueron contratados en
2019 para defender a Nicolás Maduro en
Venezuela tras la autoproclamación de
Juan guaidó Aunque su presencia fue
corta la mayoría de esos territorios
tienen conflictos enquistados desde hace
años y un gran vacío de poder una
combinación idónea que permitido que
Wagner pueda usar metodologías
consideradas ilegales por la comunidad
internacional entre sus acciones hay
torturas decapitaciones violaciones y
ejecuciones masivas contra militares
pero también contra la población civil
infracciones que son consideradas como
crímenes de guerra en el derecho
internacional además su presencia en
África se da en naciones con una
histórica influencia francesa Wagner ha
sabido capitalizar el sentimiento
anticolonial y antifrances de muchos de
estos países como república
centroafricana para extender la
popularidad rusa e influir directamente
para que gobiernen los políticos que más
interesan al kremlin una cuestión que ha
puesto en peligro operaciones militares
francesas en regiones como el sahel
donde París se ha visto obligada a salir
de Naciones como Mali Wagner se ha
convertido en una pieza fundamental para
Rusia en el conflicto de Ucrania
especialmente en un momento en el que
las tropas rusas han sufrido varios
reveses al verse incapaces de lograr
objetivos militares como la toma de kiev
El transcurrir de la guerra ha hecho que
Moscú utilice el grupo Wagner como punta
de lanza en los combates más crudos y
directos con el ejército craneano para
evitar tener miles de fallecidos entre
las cifras oficiales de su ejército una
decisión que ha convertido escenarios
como bahmud o soledar en sangrientas
batallas con esto concluimos si quieren
conocer esta y otras historias pueden
visitar los programas de France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]